this video was made possible by skill
share learn new skills for more than
25,000 classes for free for two months
and SK Alta SH / when / seven - from or
through China more than half a billion
passengers fly each year by 2035 that
number is expected to be 1.3 billion it
is one of the fastest growing aviation
markets in the world
is home to what is believed to be the
future busiest airport in the world and
is expected to soon surpass the u.s. to
become the single largest aviation
market in the world last year a new
aircraft was delivered to a Chinese
airline every 21 hours that's 35 billion
dollars worth of aircraft purchased in a
single year all of this however
represents a considerable problem for
the world's largest aircraft
manufacturer Boeing you see the reason
China is a problem for Boeing is also
part of the reason why China is already
such an enormous market for them while
the u.s. is resoundingly Boeing's
number-one customer
at least partially propped up by
government defense contracts China's
safely holds the number two spot
excluding North America China in fact
single-handedly earns Boeing more money
than every continent in the world now
not only is China a fierce battle ground
between Boeing and Airbus even if Boeing
has a slight overall edge in market
share but the company now also faces a
trifecta of issues potentially hindering
its future dominance in this ultimately
crucial aviation market the first of
these issues has to do with Boeing's
brand-new yet beleaguered airplane the
737 max prior to the max is grounding
China was by a wide margin the largest
operator of this airplane its Airlines
had a total of 97 maxes all US airlines
are presenting the second-largest
customer group only had a total of 72
this is an aircraft particularly
well-suited to China's geography with a
number of smaller secondary or tertiary
cities China's airlines are increasingly
focused on developing non-stop flights
bypassing the major hubs of Beijing
Shanghai and Guangzhou or flights to
lower demand cities outside of China
this is especially true given the huge
number of smaller airlines operating in
China who have established themselves by
setting up hubs in some of the country's
smaller cities whose populations more
recently started the transition
to the country's middle and upper
classes than those of the country's tier
1 cities of course flying to or from
these smaller cities means lower demand
for seats however the longer range
smaller capacity capability of the 737
max perfectly suits this mission that
allowed Chinese Airlines to set up in an
economical manner flights like jinan to
Singapore Guangzhou to Lahore a room
cheetah Bangkok or Hangzhou de haut an
all five or six hour flights with
minimal demand the 737 max was an
aircraft perfectly suited for china and
boeing knew it this suitability and
focus was demonstrated by Boeing's
decision to set up an aircraft
completion center in Joseon China while
aircraft would continue to be primarily
assembled in Renton Washington
they'll be flown over to Jo shine
without the interiors completed in Jo
Shan their seats overhead bins and
basically the entire rest of their
interiors would be installed by Chinese
workers in this Chinese factory having a
ground presence in China would appease
the government and by extension airlines
and the hope was that this would help
convince them to buy Boeing Jets
considering that their purchase provided
Chinese jobs this was especially
necessary considering that Airbus
already had an even more extensive final
assembly line in the country for its
competing a320 jets given the maxis
suitability though Chinese Airlines
bought an enormous number of these
planes in addition to the 97 already
delivered Chinese Airlines had almost
500 of them on order but then of course
the max crashed and then it crashed
again
China's Civil Aviation Administration
eager to maintain the country's recent
streak of aviation safety quickly
grounded the max after its second crash
making China the first country to do so
this was a rather shocking move as
historically every country's aviation
regulator more or less just followed the
lead of the American FAA in these
decisions it was thought that if the FAA
said it was safe it was safe and in this
case the FAA initially asserted their
confidence in Boeing 737 max and chose
not to ground it immediately now in the
aftermath of this the grounding of the
max has presented Beijing with three
gifts first especially in the case of
the state-owned airlines and leasing
companies the Chinese have a much
stronger negotiating position than
before with Boeing as the company works
to regain the momentum it had
for prices which typically vary widely
from airline to airline and yield a deal
could end up lower secondly China's
three largest airlines which are all
state-owned are asking Boeing for
compensation for the grounding of their
jets by extension this is essentially
the Chinese government the very one that
holds the keys to the Chinese aviation
market asking Boeing for compensation
and if Boeing doesn't comply in what is
possibly largely a symbolic move the
Chinese government could decide to
reduce future Boeing orders potentially
in favor of Airbus while Boeing is
seemingly setting itself up to offer
compensation to airlines affected by the
Maxis grounding
whatever it gives to the Chinese
airlines however favorable the company
is with them they will have to match
this precedent for their compensation
with every other of the world's affected
airlines what could end up the most
formidable Max challenge though is that
the Chinese aviation regulator has now
established itself as a leader it was
them who made the first decision to
ground the jet that started the domino
effect of other national regulators
grounding the max considering China's
regulator has now successfully flex
their muscle in this space the American
FAA which has deep links to Boeing and
is allowed Boeing to essentially
self-certifying certain aspects of their
new aircraft has lost some prowess in
its role as in a sense the world
aviation regulator therefore not only
will China's regulator likely take a
more independent route in recertifying
the max once its issues are resolved it
will also possibly feel free to make its
own independent decisions on the air
worthiness of future aircraft this is a
precedent that should have Boeing
concerned now a smaller but significant
second issue for Boeing is the ongoing
trade war between the US and China while
Boeing has not yet encountered clear
implications from this trade war some
speculate that the company could be used
as a pawn you see China's three largest
airlines china southern china eastern
and air china are all majority
government-owned and therefore their
orders can be used as a sort of
political tool to date these three
airlines fleets are slightly weighted
towards Airbus planes despite the
country's airlines as a whole on average
having a slight preference towards
Boeing but they still do operate a
significant number of Boeing planes
while Boeing is not of course a
state-owned company they are the u.s. is
the largest exporter and a major
American employer and therefore the US
government and
apartment of Commerce works hard to prop
them up as the largest international
market for Boeing China has the keys to
either help or hurt America's economy
through how many planes it decides order
in the height of the us-china trade war
in March 2019 Chinese President Xi
Jinping announced a massive 35 billion
dollar order of 300 Airbus aircraft like
China's state-owned aircraft leasing
company well you can never know for sure
this certainly was viewed as a move at
least partially intended to send a
message to the US meanwhile since the
beginning of the trade war there has
been a noticeable lack of significant
Boeing aircraft orders by Chinese
Airlines these however are most all
fairly short term threats the trade war
will pass the 737 max will take the
skies again and was perhaps Boeing's
largest problem is still to come their
largest threat is that China is building
their very own plane it's being built by
the commercial aircraft corporation of
china or Commack now to recap in the
commercial jet aircraft manufacturing
space there's of course Boeing and
Airbus then there is Embraer which is in
a joint venture with Boeing and
Bombardier whose flagship program was
bought by Airbus therefore Boeing and
Airbus control an enormous majority of
the industry aside from that the only
major unaligned aircraft series is the
Bombardier CRJ regional jet whose
manufacturing rights are in the process
of being bought by Mitsubishi there's
any Russian United Aircraft Corporation
producing a small number of Aleutian
tupolev and Sukhoi Jets and an even
smaller number of commercial jets being
produced by the Ukrainian Antonov
company these Russian and Ukrainian
aircraft tend to be mostly bought and
operated by Russian and Ukrainian
airlines so in terms of global aircraft
competition against Boeing and Airbus
there really is none it is the textbook
duopoly Commack however could break that
it may surprise some to hear that there
are already Commack aircraft flying in
China skies the arj21 this small 78
passenger jet was Comex first
significant foray into commercial
aircraft manufacturing and it has been
to put it bluntly a disaster when it was
first announced in 2002 the aircraft was
supposed to take the skies in 2005 in
reality though the first prototype
wasn't completed until 2007 the first
test flight didn't happen until 2008 and
then
to delay upon delay upon delay the first
commercial flight didn't happen until
since then the issues have not let up
the aircraft was plagued with
reliability and capability issues and to
date only 14 are in commercial service
now it would be quite reasonable to
question why this aircraft could
threaten Boeing especially considering
that boeing doesn't even develop an
aircraft in a similar size to the arj21
the answer is that it doesn't the
aircraft that should make boeing nervous
is this the Commack c919 worth noting is
that boeing is actually in a joint
venture with Commack for its final
delivery plant in Shushan but that
certainly doesn't stop the companies
from competing just by looking at this
plane you can tell it's built to compete
directly with Airbus a320 and Boeing 737
it's designed to carry pretty much the
exact same number of passengers and it
even uses these same engines as the
a320neo and 737 max but let's be clear
the c919 is not the a320 or 737 it's a
brand new aircraft by a brand new
aircraft manufacturer and it's abnormal
for even Airbus or Boeing's new aircraft
introductions to go smoothly designing
aircraft is difficult the c919 is still
in its testing phase so it's true
performance and reliability statistics
are not yet verifiably known however in
all honesty the success of this plane
has less to do with its actual
capability and probably any other plane
in the world the success of this plane
has to do with whether the Chinese
government decides it will be successful
of China's eight largest airlines just
one hainan Airlines is not
government-owned
China's government holds the keys to
hundreds or thousands of aircraft orders
why would it order from anyone but
itself unsurprisingly quite a few of the
c919 s orders to date have come from
Chinese state-owned airlines and
aircraft leasing companies it's only non
Chinese order came from GE aircraft
leasing division possibly as a vote of
confidence considering the c919 uses GE
engines the real test on whether the
c919 is actually a good plane will come
once it enters commercial service its
reliability and capability is exhibited
to the world and foreign air
consider whether they want to order it
with China's expertise in low-cost
high-tech manufacturing it could
possibly prove a low-cost alternative to
the a320 or 737 which has had some
Airlines intrigued most visibly Ryanair
who CEO said he would be seriously
interested in the aircraft if a 200-seat
variant was developed China also has
increasing geopolitical power especially
in pockets of Africa which also have
fast developing aviation markets and
this could translate to a number of
politically aligned countries choosing
to buy and operate Commack planes
overall the real challenge to Boeing is
the opportunity if they miss the
opportunity to become a dominant player
in the world's future largest aviation
market they could have trouble
maintaining their position as the
world's largest aircraft manufacturer
being number one means that a Stang
number one is the expectation not the
goal and so the Chinese market while it
is an opportunity is also a requirement
now in a similar vein anyone who's been
number one in anything knows that
staying there requires continuous
improvement that means that no matter if
you're at the beginning of your career
or if you're already at the top you know
that you should be constantly improving
yourself part of the way that I make
sure I'm always doing this is by using
skill share their courses are a great
way to quickly and simply learn new
skills for example for anyone that has
to do presentations whether it be at
school or work I'd highly recommend the
skill share original called presentation
essentials how to share ideas that
inspire action presentation seems like a
simple thing but there are actually so
many nuances to it that can really make
the difference between an ineffective
and effective presentation this is just
one of the more than 25,000 classes you
can take with Gil share all of which you
can access for free for two months by
signing up and skl de sh slash wind over
seven and then after that their annual
pricing works out to less than ten
dollars a month